[Music]
ladies
ladies yeah fellas
ladies fellas ladies
do you guys know what bacterial
vaginosis is familiar with that what is
it inform me
bacterial infection oh yeah of the
vagina they make the [ __ ] stinky
yes it is and uh i i'm reading that it's
a highly common infection
so i guess no shame in that uh affects
about one in every three women
whoa that's really good that's a lot
that means one of you in this room
already got it who has it right now
right right now
there's three of you guys one of you
guys have it one of you guys do
you see i i i i oh [ __ ]
i've had utis don't be proud of it i am
why not it's part of my body i'm a woman
proud and loud loud and proud here we go
uh you didn't ask
whatever i did so it can cause
so it can cause intense itching abnormal
discharge
burning urination and a foul smell why
are you telling this sounds like a yeast
infection
yeah good it does i don't know what the
difference is oh maybe because
in yeast infections i don't think you
burn or peas
or without that one it hurts burns when
you pee yeah i thought it does
no that's a uti yeah that's uti
all of them combined is a vaginal but
why are you telling us about this
bacterial vaginosis yeah i'm trying to
think about prime rib
oh primer is pretty good don't let us
interrupt you man for bacterial
vaginosis
uh i guess it's been a common conception
that uh
the women women who have it just develop
it on their own
and like maybe it's like they don't
clean properly or whatever
but a new study is showing that maybe
male partners are to blame it's your
fault
so doesn't that mean it's an std oh yeah
you know what that's or it's an stb
sexually
transmitted bachelor bacteria from
sexually transmitted bacteria s t b b x
g
from the bb that sounds like a cute
nickname stbp
yeah i got an stbb bb bb tb
but yeah it's they're saying that the
male reproductive
organ the penis hosts a bacterial colony
all its own
and they're saying that uh
when when you're having intercourse you
can possibly transfer a bacteria over to
the woman
which then the woman gets bacterial
vaginosis and it's not because the woman
is broken or whatever or you know
it's sturdy like you would dirty yes
that's one that's exactly what i've been
playing
girl i mean guys are probably way
dirtier how do guys get the bacteria
so i guess they try to suck their own
dick they keep the [ __ ] cheese the
dick cheese in there
dick cheese and balls sweat well i feel
bad for my first girlfriend
wait what happened there what's going on
nobody told me about it
rose i'm an uncircumcised man i was 17
years old i didn't know what the hell
was happening
you didn't clean your dick so it's hard
to peel it back all the way
that's how long you didn't did she suck
it though
did you first yeah it back and clean the
old you know how my mom used to do it
for me when i was a baby
as i grew up i grew up knowing there
you're supposed to pull it back
there comes a point where it's stuck
together and it hurts
like crazy to peel it back oh maybe
because it wasn't peeled back all the
time yeah maybe it's a frequency thing
i just remember that the way that i
realized my dick could peel back and
it's not broken
was after i had sex that dick cheese was
all up in her ew
so it peeled back in her true yeah it
peeled in her
yeah like she pop her cherry got popped
and your cherry got popped like
like literally literally it hurt but it
felt good
but like did you bleed at all that
sounds like you would have no
blood like no but it's just never get an
infection or anything
while she was looking i don't know oh
[ __ ] i mean even if she did i don't know
she probably wouldn't have told you it's
too embarrassing at that age she might
have thought that she
had something or whatever like we were
both versions
so we didn't know what the [ __ ] was
happening that's crazy that it took
so many years for them to be like oh
actually you're not
dirty it's the guys that are bringing
that in well it took forever
to find out that the the the gender of
the baby comes from the sperm
really the males are the ones that
determine whether or not it's a
male or yeah we donate the y chromosomes
because we have x
come to think of it right like doesn't
that mean
what i went through has been a normal
thing for most humans like
humans didn't for one shower every day
right so we probably all had [ __ ]
dick cheese
true and then um so when we when guys
lost their virginity
they just stuck their dick cheese all up
in the girl
maybe the dick cheese is a good thing
it's a probiotic for your penis baby
true yeah so they
they're referring to the penis as a
microbiome
in this uh is there any [ __ ] good
news coming from the men's side these
days because
y'all are trash uh we're dealing with
that we're coming to terms with that go
back to your men's circle and just let's
fix these problems because at least
they're coming to light we're coming to
terms we're
we're lighting we're like carrying the
weight for too many things now you know
what i mean because like
you know how like they always talk about
the vagina being its own like
like universe skills but no one ever no
one ever talks about the penis being
that way
i didn't even know to take care of my
dick cheese i was like
i thought that was skin that i i didn't
want to
get did you know it was cheese though if
it fell inside of her no no no like
it i didn't i didn't even know the word
dick cheese like if i peel back
it look like a part of my body and my
skin like isn't it
white yeah oh geez it looks like a
casing over the head
over the whole head uh only to the point
where it's the pee
hole yeah is it like [ __ ] calamari
like that oh god
my mine looked like when i first saw my
dick cheese mine look like
um like you know like like if you
actually leave a napkin in your laundry
yeah mixed with peeling
snake skin yeah was that put together
have you guys ever went to the desert
and saw a drying lake bed
yeah it curves up but it's it's stuck to
your body yeah so you think that it's
skin and it hurts to peel it so it feels
wrong to take you're like scaly
oh my gosh the top
giving your vagina real quick let me
wipe it off inside so here's here
this might be too graphic but like when
you're a boy
right and you get hard and you're
uncircumcised
you you can't peel that thing all the
way back
if you haven't heard it before it
[ __ ] hurts right
but in during intercourse it feels good
because you're inside but also i think
like it the friction it forces it to
push
back yeah so then i pulled it out and i
was like
holy crap this is what my dick looks
like that's like a wild dude thank you
for the comments yeah hit up your
girlfriend ex-girlfriend
for like an edible arrangement or
something like calamari
yeah but then even then so even then i
just sorry about my dick
wash like cheese inside of you because
you don't grow up washing the dick
cheese right so then you don't know but
then
at that point i would peel it back all
the way and it hurts but i'm like well
at least now i know to like
scrape off how you know you could do
that yeah because
i didn't know it could happen like no
one taught me that
is your dick okay like today like oh
yeah it's perfect
now i'm like oh thank god it's he's
making sure it's
squeaky yeah with my shampoo
yeah from his head we talked about this
yesterday oh right
so it's like dirty shampoo used to clean
your dick
it's not dirty oh okay i mean it's
coming from the head all right i guess
so i don't know
tomatoes tomatoes casey tomatoes
tomatoes there we go
so there was a study conducted in kenya
and they had 168 heterosexual couples
uh i like kenyan news it's so funny and
uh
they basically were testing uh with
on women that didn't have an infection
already and
uh to note 56 of the men have
circumcised penises
and over the course of a year they had
three checkups
one at the one month mark six months and
then 12 months
to monitor the bacterial activity over
during that time
and that what they found is that 31 of
women
overall had developed the bacterial
vaginosis
and the rate of infection was 37.3
uh if the man was uncircumcised versus
26.3
of the man was circumcised so basically
uncircumcised men
are more likely to have that bacteria
that's going to be giving women
the the bv the i believe it you know
that was the main reason why i decided
to
circumcise isaac when he was a baby was
because i had read that
uncircumcised men end up having
less likelihood of carrying stds
that could be true those guys probably
was like me in my past didn't know how
to take care of true
you're just harboring stds and bacteria
and
viruses well even if like you're a
virgin and you're not
you don't have anything right like it's
still
a disgusting area that can like incubate
[ __ ]
if you don't know how to clean it
properly yeah i've been able to clean it
properly every day
yeah like dip cheese true oh god
why didn't nobody tell me well it's just
like your butthole cause my mom told me
to wash
all of my privates and i'm like i did
she didn't tell you make sure to pull it
back
my dad even showed me maybe he could
have [ __ ] done it yeah
i would have really appreciated that
yeah cause when isaac started showering
alone
like he just started doing his own thing
i'm like don't forget
you gotta pull it back and clean it
because even though he is circumcised
like still a little just have to pull it
back yeah oh yeah my mom told me
and i was like it hurts she goes okay if
it hurts you don't have to do it she
doesn't know any better she doesn't have
a dick
but yeah so the scientists have found
that there's 10 species of penile
microflora
how many 10 10 species of penile
microflora
that corresponded with the cases of bv
so
yeah us men are more involved
with women's health than we originally
thought and so maybe we should probably
take care of ourselves more
yeah i mean there's a lot of male um
carriers of like
chlamydia with no symptoms
and then they they can be the
transmitter and all that stuff
also what like what is being transferred
through your fingers
for the finger banging because then like
sometimes a lot of times that happens
you're not washing your hands beforehand
true and it's usually yeah usually it's
like this ow and then
[Music]
yeah yeah usually it's like that and
what the [ __ ] is going on in your mouth
did you brush your teeth
that's such a high school thing to do
fingering oh i was like brush your teeth
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you